Designing a responsive site,
uses the same concepts and
processes that you go through for
a non responsive site.
Except instead of drawing
a single wide design,
there are a few more to accommodate
different screen sizes.
I like to start my design with the
smallest form factor, usually a phone.
Once that one's complete,
I move up to the next.
And as each design is completed,
I ask myself, is there a need for
a design for a wider screen?
At some point, there's really
no need for a bigger design.
By starting small I really have to
prioritize what's important for
my users.
What's the most important
thing that they want to do, or
that they're going to see on screen?
When starting big and
then designing down.
It can be too easy to just cut or
hide content that may be important.
Instead, by prioritizing content and
working up, the key content
is always on the page and
users get the full experience,
no matter what device they're using.
The design for one hardware store
prioritizes information about
the nearest store,
it's address, hours, and
phone number and puts those right at
the top so I can find them easily.
Beyond designing from small to large,
I also code from small to large.
This way, I know that my course styles,
and layout will work for
any device, even on legacy browsers
that don't support media queries.
But probably my favorite reason to start
from small and work up is performance.
By designing for
the smallest viewport first,
I'm forced to think about
performance from the beginning.
I have to make a conscious decision
about prioritizing content, and
how much data I'm sending to the user.